pressure is growing on Labour's front
bench teeth back a second brexit
referendum it's well known that some of
the shadow cabinet are open to the idea
one of those who perhaps remains a bit
more skeptical is the shadow
international trade secretary Barry
Gardner who joins us now thank you very
much for being with us I want to start
off though with the NHS because we've
heard from the health secretary Matt
Hancock
about the government said 10-year plan
it's all about what they're going to be
doing with the 20 billion pounds that
the Prime Minister promised the NHS for
its 17th birthday what she make of that
plans well look I I'd have more
confidence in their ten-year plan if the
five-year plan that they announced in
2014 had actually been delivered on it
hasn't we now have a situation where
they're 2.8 million people who are
waiting more than four hours at A&E when
we left office that figure was 350,000
eight times as many people now waiting
at A&E if you look at the cancer weights
the urgent treatment the targets that
were set there they have not been met
and in fact 150,000 people now I think
in every month actually that's not quite
true except for one since April in 2014
in every single month they've missed
that urgent treatment for cancer
patients these are the things that are
going badly wrong you you talked to Matt
Hancock about the hundred thousands
Aiken sees in the NHS and he said oh
well there's a plan coming out for that
later in the year but actually if you
look at what the Kings Fund has been
saying they're saying that actually 250
potentially 350,000 vacancies are going
to be needed to be filled in the next
ten years so we really are at a point
where it's not just a matter of having a
plan that says we will spend this much
money it's having the people who are
there capable of delivering that that
human resource is so important and of
course it's then connecting that up with
Social Care which this government has
done absolutely nothing at the same time
though it is not a good thing that the
health secretary is talking about
prevention rather than cure about
stopping people
getting two units in the future of
course but but Sophie you will see that
in on the prevention side what the
government has done is it's precisely
taken Labour Party policy I'm delighted
they have but they've taken labour party
policy originally came up with it
doesn't I'm delighted that they have and
we need a much greater focus on
prevention but but in that case you've
got to say well where is the front
loading of the money coming from and
it's not and it's also about the way in
which if you are not looking after the
elderly if you are not looking after the
people with long-term chronic conditions
and and ensuring that they get the
social care then actually they are in
the in the beds and they're part of a
system that isn't functioning we need
people to be moving through from the
health care to the social care that they
need they can't do that unless the
resources there now I want to talk about
Brett said we had a couple of weeks off
don't we with the votes coming up soon
pressure is growing on the Labour Party
over a second referendum we've had new
polling out from the people's vote
showing that the vast majority of labour
members want to see it but actually it
would if Labour don't try and stop
rights it then it will damage them
electorally that's according to the
people is very good do you what's your
feeling on a second referendum would you
like to see look we took five six hours
at our party conference to get all the
disparate views in our party together
and to sit down and to talk to each
other
and I think part of the problem at the
moment is that people seem to be talking
and they're listening to each other but
only so far as they can then contradict
what the other person has said that's
that's why they're listening instead of
listening to understand what we did at
our party conferences we actually
listened to all the different elements
of our party and we became if your party
won and we had no no we came up with a
very clear chronology and that was that
we would look at what Theresa May
brought back we would then if she could
not get
through we would then say it is right
that a government that cannot get its
flagship legislation through cannot
command a majority in the House of
Commons that there should then be a call
for a general election that is the
quickest way of getting the people's
voters you know you can have a general
election in four and a half weeks okay
if there was a if it were if it were a
referendum that would have to go to the
Electoral Commission to determine what
the question or questions would be it
would then have to have a 12-week
campaigning period it would in all the
legislation would have to be passed
primary legislation it would take much
longer so in and we've said there is if
there is a jammer election does that
mean it will be Labour's policy to have
a second referendum what we said is that
at any general election we obviously
will have a manifesto to go into that we
would set out what we would seek to
negotiate in Europe to try and deliver
so you try to personally practice we we
would try we would try to actually get
something that would reunite the 52
percent and the 48 percent of our
country every poll that exists at the
moment shows that our country is still
deeply deeply divided it is the
responsibility of government to try and
unite the country not to divide it so do
you think if there was I render my own
divisions would deepen well I do think
that but I think the way of trying to
tackle this is for us we know that the
reason Theresa May has had such a
botched set of negotiations is because
of her red lines if we as a new incoming
Labour government were to go to Europe
without those red lines we know that we
could get a different better deal and
that's what we want to try and achieve
at that stage it makes sense to go to
the country and to say here we are this
is what we've managed to negotiate and
this is the deal that we've managed to
conclude because we don't have the same
red lines as Teresa may we think it's a
better way forward and then it seems to
me at a personal level what I would then
say is that is the time that you would
then say to people now take a decision
on what we've managed differently I mean
some people would say that's chasing
unicorns to say that you could go to
Brussels and get a better deal where
what Brussels has said that this is the
only do no no no no no unless you're
Brussels have not known unless so unless
you have these red lines is actually on
immigration is sorry Brussels has not
said that they've said that what is
stopping us getting a better deal is
tourism mais red lines and a critical
one of those of course is in relation to
the customs union and and the way in
which that impacts upon the deal that
she has had to construct
so if Labour's plan is to be in a
customs union and we couldn't strike
independent trade deals you'd be out of
a job would you that well no not
necessarily but actually that is the
least of my worries and the least
important thing for the country and what
is important is that we would have a
trade policy in which we and the
European Union together would be able to
determine the trade agreements that we
then concluded okay so that is that is
what our proposal is that we would have
a customs union just like there is in
Mercosur in in South America where each
individual sovereign nation is able to
determine whether a trade agreement that
they conclude jointly with other
countries should go ahead on the EU
isn't going to give the UK a say in
negotiating its own trade deals so is it
there's nothing no it the EU the EU and
would be in a position and it's
perfectly in fact it's perfectly
possible under the the EU treaties and
to have a situation for the UK and the
EU jointly determine whether a trade
agreement with another country is
beneficial we cannot be in a position
and and this is where our position
respects the referendum result in a way
that the the premises does not and we
have said that we cannot be simply rule
takers in this situation where in a
customs union the EU could determine
that we were forced into a trade
agreement potentially with America which
was detrimental to our interests
although perhaps beneficial for the rest
of the EU and we can't be forced into
that position that's why we've always
said that a customs union that we would
negotiate would be one in which we have
a say we
cannot be forced into that position that
respects what people felt the referendum
that they didn't want to be ruled haters
and that's why we've put that in place
but if you look at what's happened in
the backstop arrangement that's not the
situation and that's that's I think why
many people are so concerned about the
next okay Barry Gardner
thank you very much thank you